okay okay it's strike up the band and
your boy psychobabble we're gonna get
Dean to the puesta del sol south rooftop
okay says put son again what's that
hidden floating above the fountain the
boss sure does like to make a
presentation we should keep it down or
else the coast yeah don't you or okay we
gotta go we gotta go what Vienna was a
big big star yeah very nice okay I had
other questions unclean okay I really
good glasses nice kind okay that where
we gotta go let's do this let's do this
hopefully it's not gonna be like 10
years long the other one going on here
okay exit I can show my main man Kanye
and clear sounds nice looking like a
little [ __ ] not like a well well [ __ ]
like one that's stims coconut [ __ ] oh
gotcha Jesus I like that guy too I like
that it's okay now let's hit through the
hole in the wall there if we go
backstage we avoid the locals
look all the wall there yeah thats ever
shirt look I get
paint next [ __ ] is this oh no leave that
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that this is a chelating
me how'd that [ __ ] oh great [ __ ]
enemies everywhere again [ __ ] he's it
gone
the Gaston doesn't do [ __ ] okay gasp on
doesn't do [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay if I shot that or not access is
that says to ooh yeah I can yeah oh [ __ ]
first all I need a live shot that's a
girl left eye yes I get rich oh good
I don't know that fun dance love [ __ ] I
need some I need some of that paste
y'all you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
there's always [ __ ] right here let this
guy here
okay like I straight yeah baby Jesus Oh
give me those stickers why don't you get
[ __ ] her brother next right to think
for this week looking for is to the
southeast I can ease it is step back of
the [ __ ] labs are [ __ ] up okay
let's do this
anything good here though Oh God
don't shut up okay
oh very nice I nice help thank you for
writing me okay I can't nothing got here
nothing got here you're at the cool
scalar area now meet you mean a this is
where I'm supposed to put on the show
played better venues let me tell you
what's that they're wiring look so what
right well look I strike up the speaker
system is the ghost people are not big
on talking in the middle of town tell
you what why don't you just give me when
those space-age cause I ever know look
you could offer me a steel clad contract
for sure you you're set
nah they well okay if i remember correct
do that okay okay there we go there we
go I'll do it I'll do it
the [ __ ] is this
that guy activate cut I got one do
another one
any more computers spray on
hmm try that [ __ ] all the way over
there was about
getting real tired of tourist season no
offense but you got it on stork actually
helpful another way [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
kind of weird that this is here I guess
no enemies I could sleep there right and
they all nice here
uh I know [ __ ] thank you 10 can no
[ __ ] thank you trying to cigarettes
that this is how [ __ ] way swing here
one ok anyway I gotta go all the outside
oops to people
okay I'm gonna [ __ ] it to that side
yeah I can do that he's crouching sale
please how the [ __ ] do I get up there
I see a little thing that back up [ __ ]
I got no
billiards
don't [ __ ] what the flying [ __ ] that's
thank you
sure glad one of us knows what or two
that I get out there
so they gotta you know this way and I
cannot oh isn't it over there okay
please just get up then yeah can I go
upstairs oh [ __ ] that food no huh in
here take this dick sure that [ __ ] here
getting real tired of tourist season
know things that you guys are lowering
the bar that cats a cafe what the [ __ ]
it's like pretty weird actually it's
getting real weird okay all right
because I can just take the show
yeah a [ __ ] fried here oh she had a
mulberry may wait ten can chumphon Shane
I'll take that [ __ ] and I got no qualms
about taking that yet ok can I go
upstairs them cuz that'd be so dope wake
up
yes okay may may not be going in the
right spot take the hopeless the door
yes maybe that's it and how would eat
[ __ ] flower to survive okay here we
go here we go yes yes yes
okay I yes eps of
hey goose that's some strong chef tough
[ __ ] burnt [ __ ] here just it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] okay and I don't hook up
five I'll take that [ __ ] i dunno i gave
a [ __ ] loader
okay how I get back up there [ __ ] not
this way uh yeah thank you thank you
[ __ ] a stall okay dad ya know like
that it didn't think much about you
powered the Holograms up where but how
do what well but listen when this thing
goes the bell jar that's where you
drinkin again love it it's a waste thank
you you find wait
you